thank you
good evening everyone and welcome to
this staffy's planning committee meeting
on Wednesday the 20th of September 2023
my name is councilor Vanessa Bell and
I'm the chairperson of this committee
members we are not streaming this
meeting live tonight due to the
technical issues but we are recording it
and by being present in the meeting you
are giving your consent to being
recorded during each item as usual
please put your hand up to indicate if
you wish to speak I will then invite you
to speak at the appropriate time
but I ask members to avoid approaching
the top table as this could create
interference with the cameras I think
avoid moving at all probably in case it
creates interference with anything
because if it's working if we just stay
very very still it might stay working
um so yes we do need people to still use
the microphones correctly they don't
turn on and off these ones as we know we
just hope that they pick up the sound so
when numb speaking please reference a
page or paragraph number and keep your
contributions as clear and concise as
possible but in housekeeping thyrex set
that way follow the Green Man
okay item
item apologies for absence and I have
the apologies for absence please
committee Clark
uh good evening chair we have apologies
from councilors Passenger and bound
thank you chairman thank you very much
committee Clark
item three minutes it's recommended that
the minutes of the meeting held on the
12th of July 2023 found on pages 7 to 14
are approved as a true and accurate
record I so move do I have a seconder
thank you councilor Neil
members any items of accuracy or maybe
just agree to those minutes by cents
good
super thank you
item four Declarations of interest to
disclose the existence and nature of any
disclosable pecuniary interests other
registerable interests and
non-registerable interests relating to
items of business on the agenda having
regard to paragraph 9 and appendix B of
the code of conduct for members members
are also reminded that they also
required to disclose any such interest
as soon as they become aware
should the need arise through the
meeting now members I think we've all
had some advice from the monitoring
officer regarding um
the applicant for
remind me hips and Chase at seven thank
you so I think we know where we stand
with uh Declarations of Interest with
that so members any other Declarations
of Interest
councilor fluke
and I know that there is a precedent for
members not declaring
uh interests when they own properties
nearby to
planning application
educational secretary report
s of police were not doing so so channel
uh with regards to a gender item sixth
um I own the Freehold property close by
it is a peculine
Communists are worth taking part in that
item and and Tim just for the benefit of
the tape there are eight members of the
public here tonight because I know we
have we did count them yeah
Mr Knights and I have checked and double
checked in the members of the public
why that's because the
[Music]
I think that's for another day Council
for Lucas so um moving on any other uh
Declarations of Interest
no thank you so we will then go to
agenda item five
which is the Crouch Ridge Vineyard
2201176 full Grouch Ridge Vineyard
fanbridge Road Old Thorne and that can
be found on pages 15 to 34. now we're
really hoping that the technology will
be kind and that I can hand over to Lisa
Greenwood to present this item please
Lisa
I certainly can with Greenwood
let's go
planning authorities
by the ocean for the applicant whilst a
couple of points regarding parking
across from Team sponsors have been
responded to oh it's a late submissions
updates it cannot be given full weight
as time has not been provided to offer
this information due consideration
notwithstanding as much the information
that needs to be contained in the
submission in particular references made
to other site support districts members
are reminded that all applications
should be assessed on their own merits
and a number of these sites were
assisted against old planning policies
and have their own individual
circumstances and conditions they need
consent
now generalizing fights with
retrospective training application
provided to be used as a visitor center
pavement Cafe and a shop with Associated
or present development which includes an
area of decades two covered areas
extractor and air conditioning unit a
gas tank container in another car park
whose site is located to the South but
Founders Road outside of secondary of
Hawthorne and as you know even
Countryside
retrospective planning for fishing was
originally granted for the change of use
of an existing agricultural Branch or
Visitor Center with storage house
standing access I follow the enforcement
investigation into one of the change of
use of the building to a shop and Cafe
the retrospective faculty with submitted
filling and planning Authority issues
refused in December 21 for four reasons
which included how Center use has not
been fully Justified there was no
functional needs an activity in this
location the proposal causes Harms in
the intrinsic character and appearance
of the rural area noise issues and
failure to prescribe
it's gone now sorry about that carry on
me me thinking it's a touch screen
available in addition to retrospective
application is required in its regard
the main difference between a composer
and a few scheme is the internal layout
this is now changed as it includes a
shop and counter additional parking is
also provided
the building measures transmitter its
wide 80 in five deep and has a maximum
height of 7 meters we'll also be
constructed with cement fiber ship like
weather boarding and the roof is
constructed with rank profile sheeting
with those Timber and Main axis is
tinned back in the building cabinet
employees and 12 part-time employees
the hours are open at the time Monday to
Thursday 10 to 10 on Fridays and
Saturdays and 10 to 8 on Sundays
whilst the description for development
may not appear as problematic in order
to meet in requirements of the local
plan policy sa which supports certain
types of development outside assessment
boundaries sets out the closest criteria
and development to satisfy the
requirements of one of this closed list
and also not course around to the
intrinsic character and beauty of the
open Countryside the most applicable
here
refers to rural diversification
recreational tourism and proposals must
be in accordance with with policies E4
and E5
exhibition has been found not to record
the E5 which are five percent tourism
policy E4 affects Agriculture and Rural
diversification states of cancer will
only support the development of new
buildings or activities associated with
Agriculture and other land-based rural
businesses where there is objectifiable
and functional needs for building or
activity the function of the code
building activities directly can
absolutely to the limiting use and the
building or activity could not be
realistically located in an existing
town here to our employment area
policy State can be appropriate to the
youth will be considered by the council
in relation to needs and the impact of
The Proposal on the site and the
surrounding area and it's by an actor
saying submitted to support the players
who relies heavily on the fact of the
bonus ancillary the wine growing and
retailing business
nevertheless the utility is a new
compliance should be assessed as such
is the term uncivious is key here and
relied upon in the submission and then
after the consider whether the use is
subordinate or secondary to the vineyard
or in fact if it is a destination in its
own right and the impact this has on the
site and the surrounding area and
whether this could be local located
elsewhere
as you can see from this layout the
building provides for a shop counter
storage room section teaching the pot
wash area bar baby changing into savings
is the guarantee that the floor plan
provides for a seating area some of the
comments would be quality support
approach of the Social Development at
the restaurant a public account and
support the extension to the opening
hours
now here are some photographs taken
to show the building as constructed
now as you can see the site's highly
visible political from Cambridge Road
and there's a signage which notifies
passes by of the cellular shop and Cafe
now the following slides are taken from
the Crouch Ridge Vineyard website during
the assessment of the application they
show you potential parking and
oversilver activities into the
countryside that can be experienced at
the site plus internal and external
music played
now the next thing it was from the
current into a young social media
platform which shows events held at the
site which included her pizza night a
post on its 31st of March says join us
for our pizza night children welcome
lots of delicious pizzas from 6 30 to 10
30. live music pizza night is back it
might be both the information regarding
these events have not been submitted to
the local Planet Authority during the
application process further information
has to have been submitted to the
world's noise whilst there is now no
technical objection on the grounds of
noise the council is environmental
health officer has recommended that
conditions are imposed on any consent to
control the hours of operation ensure
the building is modified to profound
soundproofing that there should be no
playing or Amplified music outside
including the use of PM Systems and that
a noise management plan is submitted to
an approved in writing by the authority
and it should include noise limiting
controls
by the fact that the information
provided has a lot to accounted for
external events and also if noise will
increase based on the size of events
held
but for higher information taken from
The Graduate because like in March
States the estate is perfect venue for
business client looking for hire what
happened like they're located in their
beautiful S600 sign over living River it
makes the perfect venues but this
receiving the team building like
training games but then you can keep
service here has a capacity of 100
rebounding protection but it's higher on
the venue will have exclusive view to
the point of an outdoor repairing
now based on evidence provided and
available to the local Authority the
proposed development is again in Clarity
for a cafe or restaurants which is
classed as a town center use and is
outside an existing town that Village or
employment area due to its operating
hours size and nature of operation it is
not considered to be accelerator of The
Vineyards and it's been demonstrated
that there is a fund there is
not a need called in hyperactivity in
the location and it could have been
located in an existing town or
employment area
and the commercial use is prompted and
have completed the rural area but the
paper would also first to provide
exhibition Homesite parking and this is
likely towards the Overflow of on-street
parking or further Department across
areas of the coming designed as shown on
Phoenix Landers I know to go parking has
been however from outside of the red
line boundary and cannot be taken into
consideration and hired part of this
assessment and will gain over skill into
the countryside being highly visible as
a site Advantage but it means the status
the proposal has been recommended for
refusal thank you chair thank you very
much for an extremely comprehensive
presentation Miss Greenwood now do we go
to the speakers first for George yeah so
um I would like to invite Mr Terry ink
pen first to speak please if you can
find microphone somewhere Mr ink pen
here we go
um we had a timer on the screen Mr Ink
playing something you can like get a
crick in your neck looking behind you
but you have two minutes so whenever
you're ready
my name is
times table that will be working on for
over five years
Council the section of the document
covering the Ridge homebridge Road Etc
has a guidance statement the panoramic
non-distance views to the South and the
area over the special landscape in the
coastal zone should be concerned
should be allowed which will comprise
the openness of the area
to the South
third display in 2017 planning
application I submitted to lawn District
Council 16
0271 prior reputation to the erection of
a barn to be built on the site under
consideration here this evening which
was approved with no consultation aside
that is part of the panoramic view of
the river and landscape and see a
residents and visitors are sought to
protect apparently planning officer at
the time chose to ignore the British
design State recommendations
the farm was built for smaller signers
and that approved in the application and
completely grouped windows and finish
pages of the evil behind the roller
shutters research treatment plants worst
inside and it's never uses an
agricultural building
since any officers report there's 10
further applications on the site
including the free rep perspective
of which this last one 16 appreciate the
game in the score of the field perform
into the countryside which storage
containing sheds gas tanks Etc and
concrete over more land to provide car
parking extension facility is a full
restaurant hence increase noise and
night pollution
it's a comprehensive and welcome to the
office's report refutes the claim that
the development should be permitted
under ldp policies E4 E5 as an addition
of policy as a f rule diversification
thank you very much thank you very much
Mr eggplant so now I call upon councilor
Paul Burgess
representing the Town Council so if you
could do musical chairs
that'd be great
[Music]
thank you Mr Burgess same two minutes
whenever you're ready please
consistently as opposed to this
development it has a significant
negative impact on a highly valued
visual emerging it's a caloric view of
the Crouch Valley and the brochure and
South End Hinterland
almost uniquely on the farmers Road this
Prospect is fully visible it's the
highway is elevated above the site and
the view is not obscured by Hijra
not only operation is effective but also
a wide approval of District residential
tourists and Commercial traffic
Parish Council supports the losers for
refusal one it has not been demonstrated
to the satisfaction of the local
planning Authority that there is a
justifiable and functional need for the
activity within this rural location
the development by virtue of its Urban
nature the design of physio intrusion
into the countryside and surging and
cluttered appearance of the operational
development to the western side of the
building namely but not limited to the
store gas tank fencing hard standing and
container fails to protect and enhance
the character and appearance of the
rural area three the proposal by reason
of an inadequate level of on-site
problem would be likely to cause
additional on-street parking to the
detrimentary to the free flow of traffic
and Highway Safety and could also
further erode the countryside thank you
thank you very much councilor Burgess
[Music]
and may I have the applicants
thank you whenever you're ready thank
you for this opportunity explain why I
invite the planning committee to approve
the crowdfruiting application the
planning officers recommended refusal
based on Parish Council on less than two
percent of Hawthorne residence however
other night terrors that have no
objections this spoke being backed up on
level support of the time important
which is three to one vote and over 2
500 people supporting our Facebook
petition
those have referred to policy E2 is not
relevant this building is too small E4
that they ignore real diversification
and E for and drops E5 which sports
tourist attractions the Plankton starts
to make white hard waves and create a
brand and then sell it to the public
directly and there is a demand we
produce over 4 500 bottles of sparkling
wine and over 6 000 bottles are still
alive this is increasing this is unique
in the UK but to sell Wi-Fi customers
demand food we need people to come to
the vineyard to understand the story as
English wine is still a new premium
product visual impact on the countryside
planners mentioned the Carter gas tank
that's recited by Calor Gas themselves
as the driver needs to see the tank and
a tank at all times we've screened the
west side of the building enough parking
is an issue Planet ignore their own
standards and start using external areas
to justify their huge car park we've met
the council's own standards crowd
country which has met all the external
Consultants criteria including the
Strategic theme need Prosperity who
asserts the diversification of this type
of limited existing years and both
justifiable and need to support this
sector local job growth tourism and
further investment this has a lot of
weighting on this application and cannot
be ignored please remember the plan is
all reset those are looking for cafes
now with their diversifications such as
coffee and cake at Clay Hill vineyards
next door neighbors black pig of sugar
fishing weeks we wish for members to
approve the application thank you for
your time
thank you very much so
Embers we have a recommendation to
refuse from officers do I have to second
that
hmm
cancer physic thank you
so I will throw open the floor members
don't all don't all come at once
okay cancer stamp then councilor Neil
please
um
applicants and I I think it's a
fantastic
place to go visit
I do share the concerns of many
residents about and what the offices
actually turned around and said
we need to address if they are going to
be allowed to and this is going to be
improved those issues that the officers
raised about the noise about how busy is
I mean I know it wasn't raised in the
report modern church but if you've just
forgive me I mean there are over 71 000
traffic movements on that road a week
now I mean that's a lot and if you're
going to keep increasing it we know the
status of being 10 10 and we know the
the issues we have and I know that's not
relevant to this application but I do
think it's worth mentioning
um
I really like to support
rural businesses I really do but I am a
little bit concerned about this so I'm
gonna listen to the rest of the debate
which one I'm going to vote on this and
I do apologize
I the positive I'm really aware of the
precedent reset if we go against the
officer on this recommendation
absolutely understand
um everything you've said there cancer
stamps I counselor Neil if I can go to
you yeah
with cancer stomp on that one why I do
have a question obviously one of the
reasons for refusal is the development
is a cafe restaurant which is classed as
a town center use
outside of an existing terminal Village
so does that mean we can't have things
like The Parlor Cafe in you know
um on the latch in Hawthorne that's that
is a residential do I think
that concerns me as a reason for a
refusal
again we know the movements of the B10
it's a very busy road and
hopefully parking wouldn't be an issue
I do see this as a an addition to what
what's being offered on the side of the
moment you know people coming to buy the
wine uh see the The Vineyard that's been
put in understand the story as obviously
the owner said
and people want some food while they're
there so
again I'm on the side I'm concerned with
the noise aspect obviously but
um I think they must be also a number of
traffic movements that are also as noisy
and going to increase anyway so
yeah that's my my point but I'm
concerned with the first reason people
refuse them thank you Council Neil other
members councilor fitsick
proved to be extremely important about
activity but at the end of the day we
have low development plans and the
reason we have them and they should
described as being for the purpose of
providing certainty for residents and
businesses
um
this is in my opinion in this situation
there is no policy reason why we should
I mean the officers have looked at the
lvp it says that they tried to build a
particular these kinds of outputs he
encounter parties and tried to protect
the viability of the town because they
have to pay and considerably required
late occasions
and it provides like pumps and
vegetables in the town some certainty
that they'll have football because they
we don't necessarily want to be
encouraging the residents can have to
drive to locations to and that's
something that some people really all do
so but that's not the intention of the
local abundance
very much based upon Trying to minimize
the need for people made to be and
protect the countryside now I looked at
the original application that was put
forward on this and it's considered to
dig it now than what was originally
proposed and I've added them to the site
now it's obviously a very viable
business but that isn't the reason that
the account permission to anything if it
makes money that's right in the
Clarkson's farming loads of money
so we really need to look at one is in
terms of the policy and what we want to
do with the council and do we want to
set prescriptions whereby anyway with a
little bit of rain and a little bit of
money because put a building up turn it
into a Cafe Restaurant laptop
it is
and I can't see any quality of these and
whereby
foreign
Ty
uh approved a very very large restaurant
and manufacturing center at Claremont
nurseries
and you know that is an absolute massive
building and it you know
it's much bigger than this and the
destination being a garden center
now you know I look at this as as
what it generates employment and which
is you know there's a golden trade
we can't produce that is that Rural
adversification and I would think of the
French weren't entertaining our King
this evening they'd be looking at this
and laughing because this there's no
question of Doubt is there anything it's
going to be it's all covered between the
eyes and it's going to be a huge person
um I I haven't you know I know I know
this location very very well and I think
it was just being around
we remember the opposite for many many
years there was a fine shot which was
connected to quite a small small holding
and they used to import vegetables in
there to sell them but again that was
you know
you know that's the countryside and they
they go just slightly to the the South
to which martial email there was a Barn
restaurant actually
allowed there
but the after daily Planning Commission
the the outcome was a keen on what came
back from licensing concerning times but
they've still got Planning Commission
there for that Kevin do you know I've
always supported neural diversification
um
I hear what the officers say and it's
interesting that the office has done so
much hard work proving what this is
being used yeah because to me that's the
first but I think it would be very
grateful hard if anybody to go into some
kind of business like this without
testing the market clearly they tested
it uh and and clearly they think it's
viable so chairman you know I think you
can balance well I sense an alternative
proposal
um but actually I think we should lose
silent the fact that
um
councilor Burgess spoke to the local
player his local family
but he will have liked that the hero and
see what you know what has flashlights
yeah so I mean you know
yeah I'm very concerned about the first
reason uh yeah for the refusal as well
me too so I mean I'll wait for I'll wait
for the results of the first place thank
you I'm going to say something now and
then I'm going to come to you cancer
stamp and cancer physics
because I absolutely agree with what
everyone's saying and I am really torn
we heard some councilor white the other
night talk about how the French are
thinking of buying up land here now
because of the quality of the grapes
that we're growing I saw you on towie
and I went oh look
I know them so you know clearly you
should be a little bit embarrassed about
that though but no I thought it was
great great publicity and
um and yeah it's a great business rural
business diversification it it takes so
so many boxes it really does
but it's there's a big difference for me
between
you know a wine bar that does Tap House
Foods you know rest Cafe restaurant cake
then a conference center and wedding
venue and maybe that is something for
the future maybe maybe that is something
for the next local plan but for now when
taking into account
the local plans
I'm I'm struggling I am so torn so I'm
going to come back to you that's the
stamp um
based on everything he said you may as
well just build all the way along
um wherever somebody wants to build a
building which is what cancer blooper
actually said so um I am actually after
listening to the debate and it is
I I am concerned about the the how big
it's going to grow and the disturbance
it is going to provide for the the
neighbors and yes I do appreciate its
brilliant visitors in but I do think we
need to be cautious and I think cancer
fluke has just raised the possibility of
the helium limiting and does that mean
we have to approve somebody because we
may get something in the future what I'm
telling us I mean that's certainly not
what this committee is here to actually
decide on intend to make a deal on so
I'm actually going to go with the
officer's recommendation on this one
thank you I mean I think we'd all rather
see the Crouch Valley full of Vineyards
than houses I think we've probably all
um
you know agree with that but cancer
physics
there have been applications that have
been approved for various reasons
approved so just because we made
decisions doesn't mean to say that
always right and just because we might
decide it doesn't mean
he makes another really valued point in
as much as people have a lot of
Vineyards moving into the area and we
approve this type of application and
another person does the same thing what
we're going to say are actually
that a profession that will be used
again
one of the first things in development
s more than anybody is they look at what
you've approved in the past and if
you've got something that calls for
their requirements they say you've
develop this an application these are
the means is what you
should
I really can't see how many years
thank you so if there are no other
members who wish to speak I'm going to
just ask officers if anyone would like
to
any officers like to add anything
I would advise that obviously there is
the local plan to be followed that is it
it has been shown that it is perfectly
valid local plan so I I don't think we
can take account of what's in what has
been referred to uh housing land
assessment that's for a future day and
that's a very high level assessment it's
the local plan which you're considering
against this evening thank you I'm just
going to go to councilor City Norman
quickly
before we go to the vote we're very
concerned about
it
[Music]
all over the place now I think it's
what's the point in making plans for
spending hours
[Music]
I'm sorry but I'll agree with Captain
stamp and I do think that we have to
accept that the officers have gone for
what the public actually and the local
plans are made by public
yes I do I will second that
okay so we're moving to a vote but um so
I'm going to go around every one one by
one so if that could um
be recorded constant so we are voting on
the officer's recommendation to refuse
the application so you're voting to say
you would for or against the officer's
recommendation to refuse
Chancellor finokia yes
that's what I was against cancer stamp
Cancer Center
and I will say for I will go with the
office's recommendation so
committee Clark how many is that
for the up for the opposite officer's
recommendation
okay so and it's such a difficult one
that such a very very difficult one
there
and I would hope that the applicants um
I would hope the applicants would come
back with something smaller and that or
that we can incorporate something in the
next local plan that that will support
businesses like this and enable us to
find the balance between supporting
rural businesses and you know saving
communities and preserving communities
and the countryside because I think
there is a balance to be found so thank
you members that was really difficult
and thank you again
um
brilliant presentation very
comprehensive
so moving on to
our item six which is
2300670 thank you Council Fluker is
leaving the chamber now
someone will come and get you councilor
Flocka don't worry
okay your gender item six twenty three
zero zero six seven zero full which is
seven High Street Burnham on Crouch and
that's on pages 35 to 44 of your packs
so again the screen word it's over to
you please
um
decision notice
[Music]
because EA detail to c3a residential
the site is located to the southwest of
the High Street there's a town center
boundary and a conservation area of
learnable Crouch the site comprises a
retail use at ground floor level
Hardware antiques with residential above
Nationals
[Music]
antique shop
in Planet quality terms stated the site
within the Town Center to battery and a
retail provision area in accordance with
the neighborhood plan the scientists
also had a primary retail area the site
is a time in club zone three
it's understood that the applicant of
wishes such immensely use the ground
floor front room to research related
information has disabilities to the
authority outlining these health issues
it should be this is a resubmission for
previously reduced scheme for the same
change of use of the site previous
application is reviewed as the principle
of development found the unacceptable
and owing some black the fact that the
site is in flood zone 3 and the proposal
was not supported by a flood risk
assessment
policy E2 the local developer plan
States for other types of uses that will
not really consisted unless they will
not have a detrimental impact on the
function Vitality or vibrancy of primary
retail practices by Francis is
policy EC3 of the name of the plan for
burnable crashes states that the change
in use of income that other uses will
not be supported in this location the
loss of this unit even for a temporary
period could result in an inactive
Frontage at the High Street and will be
difficult to feed say Once A Change Is
Made and could set the president for the
future the principle of development
would therefore not be acceptable as it
would be contrary to local plan and the
neighborhood plan policies
policy h33 of the local development plan
refers to accommodation specialist needs
the council will enable the provision of
housing to meet specialist needs where
there is a clear identified need that
cannot be addressed elsewhere in the
district
however a site is located flood zone 3
and has a high probability of flooding
and an objection has been raised by the
environment agency now I'll just talk
briefly about the sequential and
exception tests
thank you
specified by the national planning
policy framework as a more vulnerable
type of development their thought to
comply with regular National policy The
Authority is required to apply the
sequential test now a sequential test
will compare the site proposed with
other available sites within the
district and the aim of this is to steer
the development areas with the lowest
risk of funding
sites of flood zone 3 the applicant is
required to submit information regarding
alternative sites for this type of
development
only incense is where it is not possible
to use alternative sites should be
exceptions has to be applied now the
exception Fair shows on purpose will be
managed on the site and the
sustainability benefits of the
development to the whole Community would
need to be shown and must outweigh the
flood risk
now while some floodless information has
been it's this has been found to be
insufficient the environment agency has
asked for additional information
regarding finished floor levels and a
topographical survey however this
information has not been forthcoming and
information regarding alternative sites
has also not been submitted furthermore
an email from the agent for the app can
see the local planning of Lawrence who
confirms that conversation has to take
in place with the environment agency and
at the application understand that in
the event at the breach of the seawall
coinciding with an extreme flood event
this would Place water within the
premises until the tide went out now the
fund risk therefore cannot be managed
and that will be reminded that not only
will the occupied but recite the
endangered should the site flood that
rescue it will be required to visit the
site and it will take them away from
other emergencies across the district
therefore including other members of the
public at register
as they prepares you to increase
development of the site and the
environment agencies injection has not
been overpass proposal has an effective
charity unacceptable with regards to
flood rates is therefore recommended but
that is this application is refused as
there are alternative and less
functional sites available within the
district for the use of proposed thank
you chair thank you very much very
comprehensive again Mr Greenwood thank
you
um now I am allowed to use my discretion
to um invite a speaker up this evening
so I'd like to invite the applicant's
agent Mr Mike Lewis to speak please
if you can find a microphone thank you
thank you so you know the drill whenever
you're ready
and makes his life in Berlin 25 years
ago and on arrival of obtained planning
permission to convert the front room of
the existing house to a retail use from
which you run those antique business
Ray suffers for a debilitating form of
Parkinson's disease and can barely
manage the tight stairs to the existing
living accommodation the stairs are not
suitable for any sort of lift because
I'm able to work in the shop for second
to two years
we seek to revert on a temporary basis
only the use of the program for
residential accommodation
if granted the mission break of
remainings would be cared for
by his wife Alma
planning policy exists to support those
in this situation The Specialist needs
housing supplementary planning document
is the perfect application of that
policy
officers ask that you refuse the
application both to retain and retail on
the High Street and on the technicality
of flood risk regarding retail
use we volunteer that this would be a
temporary consent only
the room
Michael Gove the housing secretary spoke
in July of extending planning
opportunities to turn empty shops into
homes and spoke in support of making
better use of buildings we already had
avoiding the prevalence of baking shops
regarding flood Risk please don't give
too much regard to the officer's
comments whether it's a residential
extension with notable lower than the
existing no flood risk assessment would
be required the difficulty only arises
from the technicality of the change of
use
the existing flood warning scheme to its
rare helmet have already signed up would
give 12 hours or more and Cooperative
opportunity to vacate
yeah we can we'll make any concessions
to revert the property to retail that
next change of ownership or sooner by
agreement with the council I ask you all
to support rain is polite to remain in
his home and be careful thank you Mr
Lewis
thank you very much thank you so
um we have the officer's recommendation
to refuse do I have a seconder for that
[Music]
do I have a secondary
thank you thank you very much councilor
Pratt members I'll throw the floor open
cancel for your Norman please
sorry
a long time before this was changed to a
shop it was a house
um
remember that
um I don't think it's a sufficient
reason to turn down of an application
for somebody to temporarily which I
think it will be while to turn the front
room into a a residential
so I'm I vote for against the uh
representation of the offices in this
instant thank you
may I just remind counselors that um the
environment agency has objected to this
as a statutory consultee so that's
important to note
cancer physics
if not attainable situation I think in
this case it would normally have to be
for a certain period I think it'd be
very difficult to impose a condition
that it's temporary I mean is it two
three four five six or seven years it's
almost impossible for us to impose such
a condition it would have to be a finite
one
[Music]
but I think it's also equally important
that
qualities and and for us to be
government sets out to learn to protect
High streets to make sure that schools
and shops don't turn into houses so it's
a difficult balance in that because
ultimately again he goes back to walk to
our policy tell us that we should be
doing you know and whilst
we all want to be sympathetic to the
plight of individuals
there's no stuff and hint in that
position
obviously
interesting
okay that's the Stanton cancer label
please
okay Council Avon well I'm just
interested to that this building was
built as a residential home while we
went as a shop and was converted to
check use we could argue so was mine but
it was built in 1710 I think every
property along that road was a house was
a shop at one point cancer labor the
resident being able to stay put in his
family home for as long as possible and
surely there could be a condition
applied for a temporary use would safe
um of the device of the current occupier
I don't think we can do that
on the change of ownership
I think the officers were exceedingly
sympathetic to the case
um it is slightly unusual but I would
also draw members attention to the
recent floods that occurred in the west
country at dawlish where people's homes
were flooded and they showed people
being rescued from the upper floors in
this case if the property did Flood the
person we've heard that the abdicant
can't get up the stairs he will be put
in a very perilous situation in the
event of a flood and we do have to go by
the advice that's provided by the
environment agency they are statutory
Consulting
thank you well come to your current
system also I don't know um and then
cancer now if many of you have seen I've
seen some of the climate modeling and
one of the perhaps I'm perhaps one might
say more alarmist climate Maps
um predicts that the High Street will be
completely underwater by 2030.
that's not far away at all so we are in
a very
difficult difficult position with this
cancer stamp yeah I think thank you I
think if you've there's been many
occasions where there's been shots
turned changed shall we let's say tall
green cat can you remember that one
which is great which one it's all Green
pack which is now the um
yeah they can they kept some of the
retailers
but that was a fantastic but this one
allowed them to change back a bit of the
upstairs and whatever to be um housing
to be residential actually sorry to
correct you but we didn't it was office
space for the business
the top floor always was an apartment
but the conversion was off was our first
space
and I actually feel you know councilman
Norman's turned on and said she had a
Bookshop and I think that's now a house
isn't it
guys it isn't a house but however it is
now the thing is this uh can I come back
on you can Aftercare it's the same just
finished
and so um I actually don't agree with
the officer's recommendation on this I I
don't have a problem and I think it
should be under the special needs
um I think we as a community we as a
council need to actually take a
volleyball councilor fiticus said about
our policies and everything but we all
know how I bang on about actually even
having
um what are called Alexis we're not
looking after our members in our
community they are well known in this
town they must probably I don't know
their financial positions and it's not
my business the night before you say if
not leave you sit in there and say
cancel stand it's not a family issue we
are we are human yeah we look after our
communities and and I think they should
be allowed to stay there can you imagine
being uprooted but there's somebody
who's got an illness which is I'm not
breaking any confidentialities it states
quite clearly to go into a new
accommodation how is that going to make
you feel and yes Mr Lawrence you can
stop me because I'm used to being stuck
I certainly
recommendation I think we should allow
them to change it's a shame that
condition can't be put in but yeah we
can't turn around and say I feel awful
because he's sitting here what what the
inevitable is and I think it's it's
Dreadful we're actually even here
talking about it in this way but I do
think as a as a as a council and we are
a council representing our residents
here we should actually be able to put
in some horrible decisions made and I
think this is not horrible decision I
think this is a decision made but what
are the reasons
thank you I will stop you there
councilman I think we know where you
where you stay where you stand thank you
I'm going to go to council Neil before I
come back to you Council Mr Norman
please oh one counselor Pat again
um Council Neil councilman counselor
obviously I know we're talking about
policies and what we've got in place and
the primary one here is that we are
trying to ensure that retail Frontage is
kept on the High Street so that seems
clearly what we'll be trying to do we're
we lost this shot it's not been open for
two years it's never going to be over
and again by the sounds of it with the
current situation of the owner
um obviously as it's been stated the
owner has an illness and cannot manage
the stairs there's no ability to get off
the stairs currently no ability to use a
stair lift because it's so narrow
um
are we say that the officer said
obviously they would have to
um vacate earlier or they would have to
be arrested from downstairs if this was
allowed to happen either sounds a bit
really into the situation
the occupant would already be downstairs
regardless of us having this this
application through because they can't
physically access the upstairs so that
point I guess it's a valid point and I I
see what we're saying but in the real
terms in real world terms that's
you know that they're going to be
downstairs anyway they're saying they're
going to have drowned Council Neil
because that rather sounds like what
you're saying what I'm saying yeah they
would have already they'd still be there
anyway because they haven't they aren't
able to access the upstairs
so okay thank you Council
Pratt then counselor Norman again
it is it really is there is a real
reason however I am concerned
to approve this the responsibility on us
that should an accident yeah yeah
we are flying in the face
um
and yes
as we get older
we have to make difficult decisions
about the place that we lose it's so
important and probably this
accommodation is not suitable for the
current circumstance
we can look at my dear or amount of 103
she couldn't manage in the last thing
she wanted to do was to move into
account but I did because that was the
correct thing to do I think converting
this shop into a bedroom
is the wrong thing to do
for all the right reasons it should
however I'm I'm leaning towards agreeing
with the officer saying that this should
not happen
thank you Council I will go to council
Norwood again
did you want to come back yes I'm not
going to go down the road but um the
person is actually ill in the house I'm
thinking about planning
as we said earlier
the government is discussing the fact
that they consider the shops in retail
prices can become owners
in the future
now if as we as you've always said the
gentle on the gentleman is quite elderly
but however
if it was a residential home before
and in fact it was I know from
experience then they would still be a
residential area had they not planned
yet kids
and if they would have been in a
situation of having that justice so I
don't agree that we should deal with
this in the way of the applicant's
reasons I think that we should be
accepting that Tony a
business back to what it was before is
acceptable
thank you councilor Norman
councilor for took yes before we go for
advice
when you want to change the use of a
retail environment you have to sort of
marketing you would
yeah for a minimum period of time yeah
it just simply goes back to what we want
to achieve in the long run because the
problem is
developers of care I mean now look at
things and they'll say when you did this
over their white countries
it goes to apply the inspector says
the problem is is that the reasons for
changing it from retail to a residential
um it's not really relevant
um other than the fact that you know
people even wanted to be a shot or don't
want to be a shop for personal reasons
if we were to remind you to go against
the opposite effect
offices
they significant president being said to
any shop along the High Street or
anywhere else in the district that just
simply wanted to change a use to a
residential facility without going
through the market viability process or
any other process and we might be mine
as members the same will okay the
different situation we will make a
different decision but I think you know
to me these are the important factors
because
um
if a new housing application went in
would it be would it be passed no it
wouldn't not there flood zone three no
of course it wouldn't and again I really
I I'm really concerned about ignoring
the advice of the environment agency who
are probably the most relevant
stakeholder in this situation so it is
really difficult but some difficult
yeah but we know the client we know the
climate's changing we've seen the maps
we've seen the planning the units on out
there look at look what's around it it
is it is what it is I'm going to go to a
vote now I think do we want to record it
votes does anyone go for a week are we
happy to agree but okay so all those now
we have a recommendation to a few so we
are voting
for or against the officer's
recommendation to refuse
so those four the officer's
recommendation may have a show of hands
please
that's three those against the officer's
recommendation and that is one two three
four five so
we are voted against the officer's
recommendation to refuse so we approve
then do we have another motion you need
another we needed someone like going to
do another motion then please
someone's got to propose or nothing
happens that
that refuse the officer recommendation
and we approve
granting Planning Commission thank you
do I have a safe do I have a second or
yet cancel label okay so all those in
favor pardon
we can have another bite do we need
another device
right so are you talking about an
amendment
as I understand the motion that was that
is the motion yes that it will be
perfect I'll explain it will be
difficult or almost impossible to impose
a condition so it would be a permanent
right so if I
if I pose no I'm not going to propose
anything um if somebody else were to
propose that we approved with a
temporary counselor Stan would you be
willing to withdraw your and I think
what's the one looking for dependent on
the chair and the officers if we there
might be some legal precedence I've now
you know I've not looked up if it could
be temporary there must be something we
can put in to turn around and say that
it can revert that go it will revert
back up to a period of time
the only way is that
it would be if the occupier moved away
from the premises if if the premises
were sold that I've never seen the
condition put on that and I've I've been
planning quite a long time and it's very
difficult to impose such a condition it
and also I would also remind members
that you're going against it goes
against the neighborhood plan as well it
does we talked to we talked to certainly
yeah
neighborhood plans previously and now
we've thrown ours out the window so many
things
I think we might but we'll agree to
differ on that Council and I'm going to
go to cancer
remember the temporary accommodation
provided in a caravan until
mum died
um it's upstory Road they bought an
extra Caravan in the assignment Etc and
um
as a as a temporary measure so that has
been provisioned within the Morgan
District Council
it's what we make here
it's the Caravans a temporary
accommodation anyway they're not
intended to be a permanent here we are
talking about a permanent building
thank you um is it a proposal because I
think we've debated enough I think we've
debated at length so is it a proposal or
an amendment
Council Norman
it's not a proposal because we've
already made that yeah I'm just
interested to know if there is a
different Proposal with a with a time
limit on so we're just saying permanent
are we as that's what supervises
yeah he didn't put another
proposality that it could be included
and you said but most probably not
to make sure that you look into it chair
then I think we need to look into it I
think we do yeah
I would invite members to defer
consideration of the application
I think that might be I can't allow you
to speak Mr Lewis I'm afraid
I can't foreign
I think the prefer the market if there's
a way of thinking through this
arthritis
I would invite meant to that consider a
default it can come back to the next
meeting of this committee
operations
and it's a residential I could actually
turn on the side it that shouldn't be
allowed because we are going back to the
residential as well yes
I do get notifications on our texts way
of us when the tides are going to be
really high you know I'm on a river I
exactly the same when it comes 12 hours
before we get notifications so someone
living on the ground floor will be out
of that property moving into someone
else directly they know there was an
alert for a flat risk so
um because that's what a family member
would do
with all due respect again every
building down that road was a shot once
my house was a shot once everything was
so I think that's a little bit of a red
herring so we're we're in a situation
here now where we're proposing a
permanent
we've got it's safe to make cats can I
just yeah thanks it seems to me that we
have a choice we are either talking
about a permanent change or we're
talking about deferring to look at
whether we can find a president and
agree for a temporary change
so we are saying permanent
it's it's one or the other there isn't
really anything further to say
so we're voting permanent then away yeah
I propose that it's permanent well
that's what we've already got that
proposal on the table councilor Norman
so and and it was seconded so we have a
proposed we have a motion to
disagree with the officer's
recommendation and that we agree to a
permanent change from
a shop to residential use all those in
favor
one two three four five thank you all
those against
three so we have um rejected the
officer's recommendation to refuse and
we are approving that application
thank you members
so
going back cancer
Council thank you welcome back councilor
floka
[Music]
so we're moving on swiftly to a gender
item seven
two zero zero seven four nine full
Payton Place nipsels Chase Mayland which
can be found on pages 45 to 58 and we do
have a members update which you should
all have received for this application
and Lisa green was having a very busy
night so we're over to you again in this
Great Bridge
whenever you're ready
for this application and that's with
regards to regarding surface water
drainage
and the condition of this relationship
has been discharged and the word
decision will be amended as instructed
thank you this planning application
seeks A variation of the digital
application
2101240 VAR which showing the variation
for pre-disubitions infrastructure the
single story self-build live work
dwelling specifically The Proposal
receipts to vary the plans so this is in
the condition two which would involve
alterations to the scare the dwellings
the fenestration design the dwelling and
materials used in its construction and
the list of alterations I've provided
paragraph
3.1.3 of your business reports and pages
that you set up off the agenda
this is the location plan the don't go
under construction is towards the
Eastern side of the site
this is the site plan and the lower site
plan showing the access onto the public
Highway the building showed in the north
of the wide site not yet been around
actually but the slight benefits for the
from permission for Australian building
now this shows the elevation of the
left-hand image as you look at it shows
them as proposed and the elevations on
the right of the previously approved
elevations
the main alterations consist of the
addition of the brick clip alterations
the size and style of the fenestration
on the beer this consists of the removal
of a high level of circular windows in
the gables and the replacement of doors
for windows changes to the detail of the
little above the windows addition of a
more ornate fascia addition of the
platform of our straight design change
the pillars supporting the front porch a
reduction in the extent of the
asymmetric moves forming the front Gable
project projections increased height of
the larger basic projections by 0.1
meters a reduction in the height of the
chimney by 0.5 meters and alterations to
its design
the side elevation shaped following
Amendment the addition of the brick clip
alterations to apply the style of
penetration changed to the detail of the
nuclear above the windows design changes
to the pillars reduction in the width of
the overhang related to the front leg
increased height for the gaming
projections increase height and
reduction in the height of the chimney
it's ultimately being less difficult
here we have the proposed a community 's
approach will have
sorry if you give it into the sound so
yes yes an airplane
it's not don't panic don't panic
okay here we have the proposed and
previously approved floor plans the main
differences are the home offices to
become a home office for the bathroom a
reconfiguration of the invasion of
bedroom two and it's all sweet the
inclusion of the competition within the
living area and the reconfiguration of
the cupboards in the Main Kitchen
here we have photos in the access track
in the site looking next and looking
East towards the site entrance through
the dwelling Continental construction
which is visible and looking sad towards
the dwelling under construction
now this photo shows a slight access to
the street scene and neighboring
development to the north
she concludes the elephant design of the
dwelling as a result of the changes
would dilute to the architectural
variant of the previously approved
scheme has reduced the detailing
provided which result reduces the
aesthetic value of the dwelling however
whilst the design is not as positive as
the previously approved development the
overall desired scale is not considered
to result in material harm to the
character and appearance of the area
therefore our balance was the majority
of the proposed alterations would not be
positive the degree of harm
foreign
[Music]
thank you just about hug on with the
sound there your screen would so thank
you very much again for that so I was
under the impression we had councilor
Debbie down here but it Albert do we
have you all numb oh we do we have you
on teams cancel down so are you there
yes I'm here okay so start when you're
ready you have two minutes whenever
you're ready
thank you to say the least this planning
application is confusing is it a full
application A variation or by virtue of
the fact that work has been done is it a
retrospective application
confusion and listed on the modern
District Council website do not match
your description amended plans I propose
and exist in Innovations are also
proposed if previous applications get
cars from certainly
is only right the condition is necessary
and should stay one will assume that the
conditions the World falls out and is
Meaningful and not allowed to be part of
your identity today to do so is through
the Judgment that those imposing in
first instance
to apply for an increase in the value of
1.4 meters on a single story building
already nearly high enough for three
stories
the only reason that makes sense
restricting Windows is the same it
enables privacy nothing fundamentally
has changed to Warrant the lifting of
the conditions which is why I may en
Parish Council objects to this
application thank you thank you very
much councilor down thank you
okay so I believe we have the applicant
Mr Kenny Payson in the chamber please
[Music]
bear with us while we find our timer oh
here we go
we ready
yes whenever you're ready
for recommendations
the required changes are proceeded of
course Cranfield that's all about the
three Winters will see no effective laws
applied irrespective of the materials
used
this breakfast brings the building to
just over 45 quantity
the slight roof changes are purely
because of changing Architects and
literal centimeters Mountain threatened
Demolition and recognition seven but we
cleared that condition last year and now
involved and acknowledged it wasn't
mistake and now they say they are abrid
because of this constant malice and fear
we're also wanted to see it when Bush
could look at conditions 11 at 12 as
these are both unreasonable the first
condition 11 stops US building a shape
over just nine square feet
Second Kings of 12 is foreign
[Music]
local Wildlife site
I said in support of members this
evening they should be promoted
development and it is unfair that these
have been removed so please could you
prove this recommendation
of what the relative amount of changes
by also removing conditions 11 on 12.
thank you
thank you very much
so members we have a recommendation to
refuse to refuse to notes
to approve it's going to be a long night
we have a officer's recommendation to
approve and we have the applicant
requesting removal of conditions so I'm
going to hand over to the law
members what do we think councilor
Fluker
oh yes I do I'm sorry yeah thank you
Council
Joseph
okay
anybody else yes
I've read the conditions
my understanding of most
accommodation most houses you're allowed
to build shares over half of the half of
your property which was a gas because in
another three quarters of an acre
I'm going to ask your questions
and the answer came back so I mean was
you are more than a meter away from your
fingernail and you go ahead and covered
over half of your land you may have yet
and all of a sudden 10 cubic meters as
the condition says I I think it's about
six foot by six foot by six foot high
you know it's it's not a shed it's a
kennel
and I don't understand why we need that
condition
and the fact that we're not allowing
roof lights which most Bungalows and
houses now have it it just seems to
perfect us I don't understand the reason
for asking for it and I would work in an
explanation thank you I think I can
answer that if I go back to the
situation on roof lights there was a
condition that the building should
remain as a bungalow so it will be a
single level of accommodation that's why
this application is a variation to that
permission so that it will still be
retained as a bungalow in relation to
taking away some of the permitted
development Minds this is something
which is frequently done where a
dwelling is allowed in the rural area
merely to stop additional paraphernalia
as we put it it's a fairly standard
condition that we do use and the reason
is to maintain the openness of the rural
area it does not mean they can't put it
up it means that they'll have to apply
for planning permission if they did want
to erect those buildings
thank you does that answer your question
any other members
she's very good
so he only actually propose elevation
no I can't
so you know
there's no roof there's no roof lights I
don't know what we're talking about roof
lights
all the changes are listed in the
presentation about the various changes
and they're also set out in the office's
report as well yeah
I don't I don't
this is it's um condition 12 isn't it
the um
yes so you know I think that makes sense
I mean the change to the fenestration is
and everything else I sort of get that I
think the officers said that the Harm's
minimal so you know I don't really have
any problem with that but I think we're
always man
let me get better
to make sure that we don't lose
committed development rights only but
I'll give way to other members on that
and and likewise you know the rooms in
the roof you know
participation of the Abundant isn't it
so
um yeah
I'll listen to the views of members on
those two traditions
members do we have any views
I mean it does seem to be happy but it's
attention
sections
because that would be different because
the idea the objective of the variation
is it sits in parallel alongside the
original planning permission yeah it
forms part of the original planning
permission
good
okay thank you so we have um we have the
motion to
the office's recommendation is to
approve can we do by show of hands
agreed
yep I think that's a great license thank
you members
Okay so
last but not least the gender item eight
and Miss Greenwood gets to go and have a
nice cup of tea and then put her feet up
now because
for this one
thank you very very much for your
contributions with Greenwood tonight so
moving on to agenda item
800694 ADV and
it's a hint in there clearing the name
there Pages 59 to 70 and I will hand
over to miss Southern please thank you
thank you chair uh this application
seeks advertisement consent for
non-eliminated sales and marketing
advertisements Horizon of six flags on
the six meter high flag poles two
entrance signs three directional signs a
show home sign and a show home parking
sign and is recommended for approval
subject to conditions due to have
infection out of the reports which is
found on page 69 of the agenda
take you through the presentation thank
you
just a little bit of the lag between my
laptop so this is the lag between my
brain and my mouth this evening carry on
this is the uh site and sign location
plan the signs are located by numbers at
the bottom of the plan
there's a zoomed in version and you can
see the flagpoles are divided by number
one
the entrance signs number two the show
home directional signs and uh location
number three the visitor car park inside
is number four and the show home to show
my show home sign is number five
example of the um signage so here we
have the
um entrance flag in the bottom
left-hand Corner the entrance signs the
show home signs the visit to parking and
the charmer is it show home design
just the details of the black poles so
there'll be three on either side of the
entrance
okay
this is the entrance sign details
and one for either side of the entrance
this is the show home
um signs that will be within the site
itself
which
signage for the direction to the show
home these are double-sided signs so the
detailing up here on both sides this is
the color palette of the various signs
so the the flag and entrance signs will
be a combination of dark green lime
green charcoal gray and off-white the
show home and Vista car park in
directional size will be oops sorry a
dark green and off-white and the show
home signs are a combination of dark
green chamber blue charcoal gray and
off-white
the following photos are examples of
other large developments we decided in
the Burnham area which was supplied by
the app and the agent to form part of
the presentation so this is Brookfield
park
you know in the middle of the
countryside
current team in place
we're getting there hold on there we go
there's a picture of the existing
um signage that was planted under
reference 1901
203 ABD there's a picture from Google
Earth and a picture from when I took a
site visit on the 6th of September it's
it's pretty much in the same size
um
these are some photos from within the
site
there will be
yeah there you go
so this is for you from the entrance
facing outwards onto the main road
in in the entrance 18th
is that an approximate location of the
signage
so it'll be on the bank that's about
approximately 10 meters from the highway
just on the other side of the of the
ditch
the east
This Is A View to facing west
and again approximate location of where
the silence will be
it is a
picture face at the entrance of the site
facing in that building that you can see
on the left-hand side is will be the
location of the security office
huge
and there's the approximate location of
the
show home directional sign and the next
it's coming
okay this is the view of the site the
next one will be the view of you facing
the site from Terry Road facing
Northwest
that was the end of the presentation
thank you very much for that
Sadler that was very helpful
can I just ask one question so is the
proposal um if this is agreed that the
existing signage is going to be removed
or does that remain
the one from 2019
will still be under a condition which I
think can be there for five years I
believe so it's additional then it'll be
additional and the the can the condition
particularly for this one on the time
scale we've worded it so it will be five
years or until the last property is sold
whichever comes sooner because obviously
as it's a phase development we don't
know that in five years time they'll all
be built and sold so it's whichever one
comes first so do we mean all this all
sold on phase one or All Phases
well that's most interesting isn't it
because it could be 15 years 20 years
wouldn't it so members over to you
please someone
sorry I'm not sure if I had a second I'm
not sure I've had a second for the
proposal you're second at that cancer
Focus so um
[Music]
but I think you can actually see this
from space I think you can cancel them
how many signs does one need to be able
to know where a balloon is
[Music]
I think there's going to be more signs
coming on there than what you've got
when you go from North Banbridge around
the back kicks Hill coming all the way
to Burnham this afternoon I know I'm
being flippant but they have been a few
objections and that's like the reason
why I called yes
um a couple of points do we know if the
signs because of many of them are
eco-friendly because if you look at the
literature
biodiversity are we actually having
signs that can our biodegradable or are
we not because I think it's a bit
hypocritical and I know you can turn
around and say it's not a condition you
don't have to do it but it is the
thought of it and it's the if not about
it it's the reason behind it and there
is some serious facts I am being
clippings on here and I've got no doubt
it will be approved because we can't
really refuse it because I've tried
before when they did the one on the day
before some homes but you know if you
talk about what is the S2 the visual
effect that this is going to have on our
Countryside is astronomical how big are
those signs officer please I mean
they're huge that's the totem poles on
the black poles or whatever they are
that's absolutely huge six means yeah
we've got all the other signs that are
going to accompany it and like I said I
know it will be approved because there's
nothing you can do about it but I think
we've got to just make sure that the
residents
and we're representing our residents
again we're not happy with the amount of
science I don't know why we as an
authorities you have to approve so many
of the signs you've got three looking at
the the um screen if you've just done
your presentation
there's three coming around the bend are
they are they the ones that's over 24 do
I have three sorry sorry
I've got three on each side of you yes
yeah you have an entrance sign and then
they'll have three flags closely
sell this to South End I'm watching
the same story I I really am appalled at
the number of signs I mean he thought
that historical environment I'll give
you a quote and this is I'm reading this
because it's home from residence because
I bet it's the one that I was going to
read as well no go on you've got it on
paper I have to look it up please don't
cancel
I can't either
Advocates that plan your decision should
protect and enhance brand new Landscapes
and promote and reinforce local
distinctiveness
advertising six signage clearly does not
align with these principles as it
demonstrably and detrimentally there's a
lot of days in there too impact on the
local
landscaping character and in all
seriousness it is going to impact on our
parents and if it's going to be there
for 15 years do we seriously do we have
to have so many can we refuse it and ask
them to reduce the number or at least
come with something better I mean I'm
sorry no don't don't apologize and
before I go to Council of physics and
then Council Fluker I'm going to say
something which actually wasn't what
council said
um when he um when the inspector and I
know cancer flu colitis us to take
notice of inspectors and what they say
when the inspector
um overturned our decision and um
approved on appeal for phase two he made
a great deal of the tucked away rural
location and how Arnold protrusive it
was and how you wouldn't really see it
and how it didn't really impact on
all the beautiful environment Wham now
look now
I I understand the need for show home
signage I understand that the
directional signage within the site
itself I do not understand the need for
26 20 foot flagpoles
I really don't so I'd be my I'd be happy
for the applicants come back with an
application that didn't involve the
flagpoles myself but that's just my
opinion I'm going to give you cancer
physic now
what policy is this
um
right it's it is assessed under the
advertent regulations now what members
have to consider that the two criteria
are immunity and Highway Safety I think
in fact if I could just comment on the
highway safety issue again highways have
not raised any objection so the only
grounds of which members could look at
it is if they took exception to the
issue of immunity
the reason I asked is because
because we advertising the classes class
seventh day the meeting style
advertising plays a house business tax
and we knew how to remain at home at the
South it says each flag must be vertical
consumerator so I'm not obtaining houses
or less may have one flag 11 to 100
houses they have two friends over 100 I
have three flags the Flagstaff must not
exceed 4.6 meters higher
Square yeah
one year after construction of the last
house
um and so forth I mean there's policies
there and it would seem that the height
of the flags exceeds
I mean what it's saying there is is that
would be deemed consent they wouldn't
need to apply but these flag poles are
over that size
yeah they would have what's known as
Dean consent
okay
I mean if they were 4.6 meters high now
the flu then that would be reasonable
under the preventive Department yes
yes
and the snakes Okay assistant can't
sneaker I'm sorry I'm sorry okay thanks
if I actually asked for confirmation of
how tall the ones are on quickly in
place
that's asking a lot of the Settler's
head yeah
no
but I think cancer stand also bear in
mind that Corinthian place is not in the
middle of the countryside Brookfield
park is not in the middle of the
countryside none of these other
developments that the applicant has some
provided as partners of others
application are in the middle of the
countryside so I don't think we can go
like for like on those anyway I really
don't Council
because it's it's
quicker than everything else but this is
just marketing there's a question
throughout the whole District I'm pretty
sure I am sure the potato will be homes
flagpoles
so they
development
you know my feeling is
so that's my feeling you know my feeling
is
the highly controversial
um
My Views
recommendation is
members to be mindful of the presidents
throughout the districts when they
considering making their decisions yeah
to learn from and also I
uh Southfield place
in conservation here and that was the
only one that I could think of and they
had massive signs up there and
um or Countryside Aesthetics
didn't apply permission for them and
never came to committee because else's
recommendations to have proven
he said
um
thank you I wonder whether anyone apart
from the horses will be able to see
these huge Flags though because they'll
be far too high for anyone actually
driving down the road today
so members we
will have all that cancer Focus talks
about his flag we have oh hello yes
Council numb
I think we should say that they've got
to reduce the size I don't think we they
need them that high well let's be honest
with you how the places aren't that hard
so therefore I think
representing the future well that's when
you vote on the actual size
should we go to a vote members counselor
physics
[Music]
it was understood
Adventures you need to approach your son
arbitrary numbers we put forward in the
data well I think I know the answer to
this oh hello yeah I think I think I do
um I can remember something
indictment where they got into this and
they actually went to seven and a half
pieces and I didn't understand
medication until what's been said
tonight and if you look at the flags in
that particular one if you if you put
them at four meters and then you've got
a two meter flag on it someone's just
gonna come along this door high up extra
bag and
Savannah
Zoo the higher they are the lessons
that's quite useful that's no cancel
thank you for sharing that that's uh
every day is a school day
assure you that I've got them outside my
kitchen
yes
and I've never seen anybody trying to um
is there anything we can do can we defer
it to get more information or not
because it is it is
probably 15. I know I know and what I'm
six why do we need six
standard cancer but I don't really want
to reduce
um
appeal
I think it's excessive I mean it's
really excessive I think it's looking at
the number of other developments in the
bower all the signs I in fact I came
past some signs on the outskirts of
Malden this evening and they had far
more than that I think I lost count of
20.
and they've now encroached on the field
adjacent I mean
if if members want to we can't go back
but
I could you ask them to lower it and if
not I don't know
I'm going to because we're going back in
circles
I think it would so members can we do
this by a show of hands all those in
favor of a
accepting the officer's recommendation
to approve please raise your hands
one two three four five all those
against
three and I'm abstaining so that is that
is past
so office's recommendation to approve
thank you members so item nine any other
items of business that the chairperson
decides are Urgent now there is one I've
been informed that we are likely to be
on full fiber here by next month that we
are having full fiber installed in this
Council chamber so hopefully moving
forward that will be in time for the
next South Eastern animations
[Music]
you know we do so anyway members I just
wanted to update you on that so that was
the only item so members at 2112 I
declare this meeting closed thank you